so what you got what's interesting to
you okay so I'll start with one that we
went go-karting a couple weeks back and
so I'm really into kind of VR AR I mean
you know this I've kind of gives you an
oculus so you can you know feel my you
gave him one great gift that's awesome
yeah I was like John you got to do this
you're never gonna buy one on your own
you're gonna be a skeptic forever
here you go are you using it yeah
because he was telling me he's like
there's just one thing your cuz I was
skeptical I was like is there any good
games like what am I gonna do with this
and he's like dude you gotta try this
PokerStars thing and I was like oh yeah
what a VR poker why do I need that it is
amazing have you tried this
thing why done boxing I played all the
games but I think gotta try the poker
one it's incredible
I'm gonna go buy an oculus just to play
yeah seriously you should there are sold
out so it's gonna be tough but you know
maybe we can get you one too you really
can't buy one right now they're out
there totally from from Christmas they
just completely sold out and then they
haven't been able to refill it they said
it was January than February now it's
March and then they're talking about all
these delays from China that's a good
sign for VR yeah I mean they totally
it's the first device where I looked at
it and I said I can give it to somebody
that's not a VR junkie and they would
actually get excited about it and I
think the poker one is great because you
actually people want to build these
really immersed experiences like boxing
but actually you don't really want
entertainment like that all the time I
actually want more sit on the couch
experience yeah and so you know some of
the things I've been thinking about in
VR say what can I build while I'm on the
couch yeah and so we wouldn't go karting
and you know when you go go-karting it's
really about how quickly do you make
these turns how fast are you how good of
a driver are you you know how aggressive
are you you know things like that and
afterwards we're just kind of talking
about some ideas and I was like dude
it'd be cool if we could you know go to
a go-karting place but it's like Mario
Kart instead where you have these AR
goggles over your head and it's not
about quick turns and it's like a longer
track where you can kind of like have
some space but I you know would
digitally go over this box and I now
have a weapon but I could shoot at your
car and if I hit you successfully your
car kind of shuts down for a second and
you're stuck so I think the real life
Mario Kart is this like the sandbox
thing so this would be like sandbox or
like Museum of ice-cream it'd be a place
you go
put on this thing play with a bunch of
fun big on your sandbox like laser tag
it's like a laser tag do you think that
sandbox is a big business
I think sandbox is fantastic I mean it's
hard to see if it's gonna be successful
or not because retail has all these
problems and having space has all these
problems but if they retail well yes not
retail but they're they kind of have
retail spaces right like they want to be
brick-and-mortar right yeah they want to
be like in a spot where there's a lot of
I mean just it's just an activity it's
just like escape room or something it's
like escape room but it escape remain I
know I know guys who owned like 200
escape rooms are they awesome it's an
amazing business because escape rooms
are super lightweight you don't do
anything you have a room if one person
you buy the kit and you just keep like
reassembling the room and you have these
like very small fun big as that company
well it's not one company but it's like
like you can just own a different yeah
but like rooms you can own a McDonald's
franchise they still report revenues as
one yeah
[Music]